Do you think you can hold off regulation though?
You did.
Do you think that by these approaches and by being proactive and by taking a
standard,
perhaps offering up a road to redemption to these people and making clear
distinctions between what you're,
what you're allowing,
what you're not allowing,
you can hold off regulation or do you disagree with what he's saying about
regularly?
I believe that should be our goal is to hold off regulation.
I believe we should be,
we should participate like any other citizen,
whether it be a corporate citizen or an individual citizen in helping to guide
the right regulation.
So,
uh,
are you familiar,
and I could be wrong on this because it's been like 15 years since I've done
this.
Are you familiar with the clean water restoration act at all?
I don't expect you to be.
It's a very specific thing.
So,
uh,
it was at some point in like the early seventies there was a river in Ohio,
and again,
I could be wrong.
It's been 15 years.
I used to work for an environmental organization,
started on fire.
And what was typically told to us was that all of these different companies
said,
we're doing the right thing.
But like as I mentioned,
the snowflake doesn't blame itself.
So over time the river was so polluted it became sludge and lit on fire.
And so someone said,
if all of these companies think they're doing the right thing and they've all
just contributed to this nightmare,
we need to tell them blanket regulation.
And so what I see with these companies,
like banking institutions,
public discourse platforms,
the distribution,
I actually,
I'm really worried about what regulation would look like because I think the
government is going to screw everything up,
but I think there's going to be a recoil of a,
at first I think the Republicans,
because I watched the testimony you had in Congress and I thought they had no
idea what they're talking about,
nor did they care.
There was like a couple of people who make good points,
but for the most part they were like whatever.
And they asked about Russia and stuff,
so they have no idea what's going on.
But there'll come a time when you know,
for instance,
one of the,
one of the great things they brought up was that by default,
when someone in DC signs up,
they see way more Democrats than Republicans.
Right.
You remember that when you testified?
Yeah.
So,
well that there's an issue and I don't think,
I believe you when you say it's Algorithmic,
that these are,
you know,
prominent individuals.
So they get automatically recommended.
But then there,
you know,
so again,
the solution to that,
like how do you regulate a programmer to create an algorithm to solve that
problem is,
is,
is crazy,
or you're regulating someone to invent technology.
But I feel like there'll be a backlash when too many,
right now we're seeing the reason,
one of the reasons we're having this conversation is that conservatives feel
like they're being persecuted and repressed.
So then it's gonna escalate from,
it's not going to stop with these conversations.
And so that we're,
we've been having a lot of talks about this,
particularly around algorithms.
And,
um,
one of the things that we are only focused on is not just fairness in outcomes
but also explainability of algorithms.
And I know Jackie,
you love the steps.
I don't know if you want to talk a little bit about our work there and
we,
um,
so there's two fields of research within artificial intelligence that are rather
new but I think really impactful for our industry.
One is fairness and ml.
Um,
so you're guessing what fairness and machine learning and deep learning.
So looking at everything from what data said is fed to an algorithm.
So like the training data set all the way to how the algorithm actually behaves
on that,
on that data set,
making sure that it,
it does not develop bias over the,
um,
launch longevity of the algorithms use case.
So that's one area that we want to lead in.
And we've been working with some of the leading researchers in the industry to
do that because the reality is a lot of this human judgment is moving
algorithms.
And the second issue with it moving now rhythms is algorithms today can't
necessarily explain the decision making criteria that they use so they can't
explain and the way that you make a decision,
you explain why you make that decision.
I read them today or not being programmed in such a way that they can even
explain that you may wear an Apple Watch for instance.
It might tell you to stand every now and then.
Um,
right now those algorithms can't explain why,
why they're doing that,
right?
That,
that's a bad example cause he does it every fit,
every 50 minutes.
But um,
as we offload more and more of these decisions both internally and also
individually two watches and,
and two cars and whatnot,
there,
there was no,
uh,
there's no ability right now for that algorithm to actually go through and list
out the criteria you use to make that decision.
So this is another area that we'd like to get really good at if we want to
continue to be transparent around our actions.
Because a lot of these things are just black boxes and they're being built in
that way because there's been no research into like,
well how do we get these algorithms to explain what their decision is?
That question hasn't been asked.
My fear is it's technology that you need to build.
Yeah,
but the,
the public discourse is there.
We know that foreign governments are doing this.
We know that democratic operatives in Alabama did this.
And so I imagine that,
you know,
with Donald Trump,
I,
you know,
he talked about an executive order for free speech on college campuses so that
the,
the chattering is here.
Someone's going to take a sledgehammer to Twitter,
to Facebook,
to youtube and just be alike.
Not Understanding the technology behind it,
not willing to give you the benefit of the benefit of the doubt and just saying,
I don't care why you're doing it.
We are mad.
You know what I mean?
And then pass some bills and,
and then it's over again clarifying.
I,
I think you guys are biased and I think what you're doing is dangerous,
but I think that doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what you think is right.
It matters that all of these companies are doing similar things and it's,
and it's,
and it's already terrifying people.
I mean,
look,
when,
when I saw somebody got banned from their bank account,
that's terrifying.
And paypal has done this for a long time.
You know,
it seems like more grievous than being banned from any social justice or social
media platform that,
that seems to me to be worthy of a boycott.
Patriot Patriot issued a statement about a man,
I believe his name is Robert Spencer,
and they said,
mastercard instructed us to ban him.
And you know what,
you know,
I'll say this to me mentioning chase,
paypal,
mastercard terrifies me.
I'm on the Joe Rogan podcast right now,
calling out these big companies in defiance.
I would like to know all the specifics of why they chose to do that.
And I would hope that they would release some sort of a statement explaining why
they chose to do that.
Maybe there's something we don't know.
There was a,
there was a reporter,
um,
and I could be in this wrong because I didn't follow it very much with big
league politics.
Who said that after reporting on paypal negatively,
they banned him.
That's terrifying.
So less reporting on it.
In what way?
To Sargon off a cod issue.
No,
apparently is a journalist.
He wrote about something bad pay pal did league politics is conservative.
And so all of a sudden he got a notification that they can't tell them why,
but he's gone.
So I see these big tech of monopolies.
I see youtube,
Facebook,
Twitter.
I see paypal,
mastercard,
and they're doing it and they all say they're doing the right thing.
But all of these little things they're doing are adding up to something
nightmarish and some,
some writing legislator's going to show up and in a matter of time with a
sledgehammer and just he's in whack.
Your Algorithm.